asteroid Apophis is something that is
going to come really close to Earth on
April 13 2029 Apophis will pass at the
distance of 4.9 Earth radii which is
about one tenth of the earth-moon
distance at the time when Apophis was
discovered in 2004 it had this chance of
impact to 4% and that is kind of the
highest probability that we ever know
for any other asteroid a kilometer sized
object which is kind of really global
devastation something that sighs coming
this close yeah this one is the the
closest that we know of first thing you
do is like okay who can get more
measurements and then you pull all the
resources see all the telescopes see if
you can get it with radar because the
odds are with more measurements the
chances of impact is going to disappear
last time we observed it in January 2013
we got some really really precise
measurements off its position resulting
in a very precise orbit determination
they have completely eliminated any
chance of impact so the statistics for
it for Earth impacts is something that
is very small that happens probably once
every several centuries something that
is large or something that we should
really worry about those are in the
orders of like five hundred thousand
years two million we were looking at
some very rare events and I think it's
important to note that we have
discovered more than 95% of the objects
that are kilometer in size are larger so
if there were any big asteroids in the
earth population we would have found
them by now